- I am happy to be
covering for Kelly today.
She was, you know, I've
never hosted a show before.
This is my first time hosting any show.
(audience cheers)
I've never hosted a show.
So she was kind enough to leave me a note
with some hosting tips, especially for me.
So here we go.
This is a note from Kelly.
"Hi Kumail.
Thank you for taking such
good care of my show."
Aw, don't get ahead of yourself, Kelly.
I just started.
(audience laughs)
Things could go south.
"I truly appreciate you guest hosting
and making Marvel movies."
Oh, that's kind.
"Here are a few tips
while you're at the show
that may help you.
Tip number one, compliment Rubin's suit."
(audience laughs)
"He warms up the audience"
(audience cheers)
"and will get them extra warm
if you tell him he looks nice."
Man, you look really nice.
- Give it up for my man, come on.
- [Kumail] Look at that.
- Yeah!
- That's very sharp.
That is very sharp.
Well done.
"Tip number two, the
band will play a sting
whenever you say, welcome
to Chippendale's Takeover."
(band plays)
Yeah, thank you.
I should take you guys around.
That's an awesome thing to
just have happen in my life.
"If you scream, I'm
wearing lace underwear,
something awesome happens."
I'm wearing lace underwear.
(audience laughs)
"Just kidding about that last one."
Thanks a lot, Kelly.
(audience applauds)
"Thank you.
Have fun."